around the United States there is
outrage over the police shooting of
Michael Brown in Ferguson Missouri maybe
because it isn't the first time an
unarmed black man has been gunned down
by cops what appears to be little reason
protesters have called for justice to be
served but will it be looking back might
give us a clue so here are four infamous
police brutality cases in the United
States and what happened to the cops
involved Rodney King his case put u.s.
police brutality on the radar for an
entire nation we all get along in 1991
he was beaten by four white LAPD
officers after a high-speed chase if it
hadn't been taped King probably would
have been just another black man
brutalized by the cops but it was still
that didn't stop a jury from acquitting
the officers of all criminal charges
leading to the LA riots some of the
worst in US history this language
the LAPD did however make some changes
adding more diversity to the then fifty
nine percent white force and the city
got a new police chief smart King sued
Los Angeles and won and in 1993 two of
the four officers were convicted of
violating King's civil rights in a
federal case they were sentenced to 30
months which they served 41 that's the
number of bullets police fired at amadou
diallo in front of his apartment
building he was 22 and unarmed the
plainclothes officers who all happened
to be white thought he had a gun it was
actually his wallet a year later they
were all found not guilty of criminal
charges and not one of the officers had
to resign so what happened the jurors
did not want to believe that what they
did was criminal they viewed it a
mistake there was a bit more justice
though in New York City policing the
street crime unit that the officers were
a part of whose creepy slogan was we own
the night was disbanded the city started
recruiting more black and Latino
officers and for the first time the
police had to release data on its stops
and arrests specifically when it came to
race
fast forward seven years 23 year-old
Shawn Bell was celebrating his last
night as a bachelor in Queens New York
five plainclothes cops and unmarked cars
fired 50 shots into Bell's car killing
him and wounding two friends they
thought the group had a gun they thought
wrong
three of them were charged and found not
guilty of criminal charges but in the
years that followed one was fired and
the others were forced to resign from
the force still only one was denied a
pension
so his justice actually served New
Year's Day 2009 Oscar Grant was shot in
the back by an Oakland Transit Police
Officer even though he was already in
handcuffs and lying face down on the
ground the officer said he confused his
gun for a Taser
the incident was filmed by onlookers
with camera phones and spread quickly
online grant died the next day and
Oakland erupted in protests and riots
the officer Johannes Messerly was
convicted of involuntary manslaughter
and got the minimum sentence of two
years in prison but he was released 11
months later on parole John Burris
attorney for grants family explain why
cases like his are hard to win the vast
majority of people who serve on the
juries are basically Pro police and it's
very difficult for them to rule against
a police officer for conduct that
happened in the course of their work
grants along with bail Diallo and King
are all symbols of the ongoing fight
against police brutality for every
generation the common thread excessive
force and little accountability will we
ever come up with a way to cancel cops
gone while and when will communities be
able to end their cry no justice no
peace
subscribe on YouTube follow us on
Twitter and like us on Facebook